Barbara Bush said you don't luck in the
things as much as you'd like to think
you do you build step by step
whether it's friendships or
opportunities Barbara Bush's wisdoms
renowned of course and I completely
agree with it what is interesting is is
that you know we've all heard the
butterfly effect right the butterfly
flaps his wings and it moves molecules
of air into motion and so many days or
months or years later on the other side
of the world that has built up and
becomes a hurricane right but what's
interesting is our life actually does
work that way sometimes things happen to
us that feel like they were coincidence
or chance and really they are the result
of unintended consequences of you push
something and it took a while for the
dominoes to go around through the design
and come back and hit you positively or
negatively but we do really reap what we
sow how you treat people how you
interact with people you know whether
you try to screw people around whether
you just tell the truth you know all of
that well you're kind whether you're
generous
whether you're selfish these things you
know whether you work hard
whether you steal for Yoram from your
employer and then can't figure out why
you can't get a promotion and then
amazing by the way if you come in late
and you don't work while you're at work
did you know you're stealing but then
wonder why you can't get ahead and not
weird that's where people wonder hearing
people all I could get ahead and you
know okay you do the wine walk around
the lip stuck out and and then they you
know
well yeah you can't get a hand because
you know hey yeah maybe try like having
a little energy smiling working while
you're at work and actually adding more
value than you cost and guess what
people will notice you and if your
employer doesn't notice you and
appreciate you someone else will and
steal you I will never forget the first
time I saw this happen I wrote this in
one of the
years ago we don't remember which one
but my mom and dad I was I was a
probably 13 years old or 12 years old or
something like that might have been 15
somewhere right in there in my teens we
went to what we thought was a nice steak
house and it was a pretty nice steak
house and we had a lady that waited our
table and it was not this is not a cheap
place this was a decent for us at least
to growing up it was a high-end place at
a white tablecloth so shut up you know
and the lady waiting the table was over
the top I mean she was not bothering us
but she the service level and her smile
and just her presence was just amazing
my dad on the real estate company and
you don't he did he talked her into
coming and getting her real estate
license he hired this lady from the
steakhouse and she became a million
dollar seller back in the 70s because
you know they weren't paying her what
she was worth because you can't make
what she was worth waiting tables she
was worth a lot more than that because
of this what she brought to the table
but but literally and figuratively and
symbolically and metaphorically and
everything else there okay but I mean
you see what I'm saying when you add
more value in a place even then you are
is necessary to quote do the job unquote
if if they can't or won't pay you there
someone will steal you and give you that
opportunity you don't look into things
as much as you'd like to think you do
you build step by step whether it's
friendships or opportunities Barbara
Bush hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]